Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is
going to be my new stranger things season 4
teaser trailer it was stranger things day so
they released this new footage they posted a
bunch from behind the scenes so we'll break it
all down if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos we'll do
a new amazon giveaway all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and post all your theories
about how hopper survived the end of season three
we're just starting with the big stuff first
obviously the big callback here with the dice
roll as they're filming season 4 episodes is the
dungeons and dragons game from the very first
episode now the last time that they actually
tried to play dungeons and dragons on the show
it was actually will that tried to get them to
play but none of the other squad wanted to have
anything to do with it so it seems like they're
sort of bringing this back around to the beginning
of the show usually you see series do that have
big call backs to the beginning towards the end
of their run but season 4 isn't going to be the
last season of stranger things the duffer brothers
already revealed that there would be season five
stuff happening but they haven't talked too much
about what the story that's going to be we still
got to find out what's going on with hopper they
still have to rescue him and they still have to
deal with the russians they've already revealed
that the title of stranger things season 4 episode
1 is the hellfire club and now dusty himself has
been posting pictures with a shirt of the hellfire
club so it actually sounds like it's going to be a
real thing on the show the most notable reference
would be to the marvel x-men hellfire club and
chris claremont would actually be on the x-men
comic book during this era while stranger things
is happening during the 80s he wrote on the x-men
comics for about 17 years haven't seen a whole lot
of actual comic book references inside stranger
things usually it's just a mishmash of all kinds
of 80s pop culture references from all over the
writers on stranger things revealed that there
would be an extra episode during season 4 they
posted this stack of all the scripts there are
nine different scripts here meaning nine episodes
instead of the traditional aid they did that back
in season two to give 11 that side episode the
side quest where she went to find out the girl
who survived the program just like her that kind
of felt like they were trying to set up some sort
of spin-off that never wound up happening but
maybe they'll bring that back around and pay
it off during season 4 or season five so there's
a whole other person out there that has the same
kind of powers that eleven has but i think she's
always supposed to be the most powerful person on
the show so i'm not expecting some deus ex mac and
a person to walk out and say i'm way power than
all of you i'm going to solve all these problems
but then we have the footage of hopper showing
up on the chain gang in siberia russia which is
obviously the continuation of what's happening
since he's been locked up in that kumchaka russia
siberian prison the whole idea here is that the
russians in season three were just the tip of the
iceberg the whole reason why they came and created
that mall was to mask their activities because the
location inside russia where they were trying to
penetrate the upside down and cross the barrier
between dimensions just wasn't strong enough the
barrier wasn't weak enough so they came back to
the original site in hawkings and because each
season they try to present some larger threat some
larger big bad they try to make the russians in
season 4 seem even worse than the russians from
season three like you thought they were bad this
part of the russian military here are the ones
that were bankrolling that operation the ones that
were experimenting it seems like they're trying to
domesticate a demogorgon here they kind of implied
that they got it through their experiments back
in hawkings because they have that cage that looks
like it belonged to the demogorgon but it's empty
and then it just shows up at the end of season
three we still don't totally know how hopper
wound up in that russian prison but it's likely
that there was just this missing period of time
between when that explosion went off and when the
authorities came down that other russians survived
and just grabbed everyone they could and took them
back to russia they'll probably have an episode
where they flash back and show you how he survived
like he fell under some large piece of metal that
protected him from the bulk of the blast passed
out and then just woke up inside the russian
prison there were a lot of people that wondered
because of the barrier between the upside down
if he actually traveled through the upside down
or the russians have found a way to travel through
the upside down one of the better theories too i
think the fact that they're laying this track here
in siberia what is it for is that it might have
something to do with what they're trying to do
inside the upside down because anything that you
create in the real world also exists in the upside
down so the russians might be trying to weaponize
the upside down and use it as a dimensional
gateway to other parts of the world like obviously
this is the height of the cold war so if you're
thinking about 80s movie references you have
the idea that the soviet union could potentially
take over the world eventually that was the threat
they might just be working that into the themes
of stranger things in the upside down because
it's basically a dimensional gateway you could use
it to travel anywhere you want in the multiverse
if you could figure out how to do it that would
be one reason to lay all this track here is that
so you could actually create some sort of railway
to carry all your troops and your weapons through
the upside down to various points all over the
world almost instantly really love the jack and
hagar shout out here he just seems like he's the
upgrade to the russian terminator character from
season three obviously a big arnold schwarzenegger
terminator reference during that season we'll
see what kind of references they make with jaqen
h'ghar's character but he typically plays really
badass assassins in all the series and he's kind
of typecast as that but he is really good at what
he does there really isn't a lot of information
in the new teasers about what's going on with
the mind flayer right now because they haven't
completely defeated it they just defeated its
avatar at the end of season three billy sacrificed
himself so that they could take it down but that
was really just the mind flayers flesh puppet that
it was using across dimensions so the actual mind
flare the real big bad itself is still just fine
inside the upside down it kind of implies that
if they're going to get rid of it for good they
have to do it inside the upside down and there is
that other teaser that says we're not in hawkins
anymore just implying that they will be going back
inside the upside down but even though they all
take off at the end of season three like it seems
like they're leaving hawkins most of the stranger
things season 4 footage shows some of them on the
set inside hawkins so it seems like some of them
are coming back and you do have to remember that
the easiest place to get into the upside down
is in that hawkins gateway but if we're talking
about ending the series finally defeating the mind
player you have to remember if season 4 isn't the
end of the show and they'll go into season five
like the duffer brothers are saying then they
won't actually kill the mind flayer during season
4 pretty safe bet they're going to end on some
giant wtf moment cliffhanger just like they did at
the end of season three heading into season 4 just
in terms of actual release date though originally
it seemed like they were going to go with a
christmas theme for season 4 and they were going
to try and release it around this time towards the
end of 2020 obviously that's not going to happen
now because of the big virus delay they're not
done filming season 4 episodes yet so i'm assuming
that they'll try to release it sometime in the
first half of 2021 hopefully by the spring if they
don't want to sit on it and wait till the end of
next year to release it but i don't think they'll
do that but if there was any question obviously
the big things at the beginning of the season
are one finding out that hopper is still alive
11 getting her powers back and realizing he's
still alive and then going to rescue him before
they figure out what to do about the russians just
in terms of the way they typically pace things
like this out especially with series that don't
have high episode counts is this reveal of 11
finding that her powers are back and them learning
that hopper's still alive is all something that
they'll deal with at least by the end of episode
one like when the season picks up they still think
that they've defeated the mind flayer so they
think that all their troubles are gone they're
still kind of trying to get over the loss of
hopper trying to deal with that emotionally but
then maybe his life is slowly going back to normal
then playing dungeons and dragons again something
happens in alerts 11 her powers sort of come back
and she senses that hopper is still alive and
that's what sets them off the rest of the episodes
so everyone post all your theories in the comments
about how the gang the hellfire club is going
to rescue hopper at the beginning of season 4.
there'll probably be another stranger things
season 4 trailer of some kind in the next couple
of months once they eventually wrap filming in in
related netflix news the witcher netflix season 2
filming episodes with henry cavill and all the
actors so we'll probably find out more about
that as well while that's happening we still have
the mandalorian season 2 star wars episodes and
we have the avengers 1 division marvel episodes
coming up by the end of this year too so even
though everything's been delayed so much there
still is some really cool stuff coming up before
the end of the year while you wait for everything
click here for my other brand new stranger things
season 4 teaser trailer video and click here
for my brand new mandalorian season 2 episode
2 star wars video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!